well they've led the entire way largest
lead 20
and right now 16 as we open the fourth
oh what a nice pass
caruso throws it down that was during
the timeout
as they continue autism awareness man
ingles by the way has a now a
career-high 12 assists williams
flips it up and in caruso is doing some
things mike
even the crowd reacted to that pass how
pretty it was
hey look at this okay put a little sauce
on it
that is nicely done now caruso this is
only his 18th game in the nba
tonight the lakers can score now there's
some pressure on the thunder
that's a poster on stephen adams did you
see
yeah turns the corner
stephen adams rotates slowly and swipes
and caruso says yes
i have hops oh look at that focus
top team in the west magic number four
golden state
is three rondo three up high and off the
road
caruso parachutes in
for cousins everybody got out of their
feet here is caruso came
off the weak side and puts in the jam he
is one of seven well that's special
just a moment he gave everybody a jolt
we'll take a break then take you to the
american express halftime report
james got it out to caldwell pope
caruso oh you didn't know he had that in
his bag did you
well alex caruso is more athletic than
you think
and he worked hard on his body goes to
the room with authority and leaves no
doubt
mr cleveland might have been better
served to step to the left
lebron gets it right back with danny
green by the back to green
on its way does not go down oh the
caruso
this shot by danny green dwight thinks
he's got an offensive rebound all of a
sudden
here comes caruso nobody put a body on
him and he put a highlight play
up into the stands here
six on the shot clock zion for the
runway against howard danny green
got a hand on it now caruso runs a break
caldwell goes to the wing here's
james oh punch it home lebron
[Music]
how they're gonna get it because they
just certainly haven't been
as motivated as some of these other
teams down the middle goes
ac
the white side is going to have to earn
it at the free throw line
taking the screen and going to the rim
getting the angle on right side
right side not able to get over to
contest that shot that's stolen by
hardin
harden goes up inside blocked by caruso
from behind
terrific recovery and defensive play for
caruso and then put the head down and
blame somebody else caruso does a great
job coming
from the back court chase down block
number three anthony davis
as their fifth starter but he is so
important as a screener
and a roller coaster mclore blocked by
caruso
caruso that's great effort to drive by
but gets back into the picture
blocks it without falling lebron
stumbles
and throws it away mclaughlin's got it
all the way
caruso with the defensive play get it
out of here
the kuru show and that this after lebron
hits a wet spot tries to get it to
caruso
but is taken out of the air by
mclaughlin but
just had the biggest lead of 20.
if you're going to attack you should
attack for the reason and that's a great
job
cut bounce pass and finish
fly caruso
you must be able to throw it down we
don't see that often
crowder misses the three james stolen by
payne james gets it back caruso
up to james for the slam what a wild
play
and the lakers go back up by four lebron
james has it
in his tank russo doesn't make this play
a couple of weeks ago
but he trusts that lebron james has the
ability
the athleticism and the health to go get
it off the backboard
absolutely beautiful turning back time